and a very good evening to all of you
uh to begin with my journey uh with pine
biotech
firstly i am an undergraduate biomedical
sciences student
so when i was in my first year i joined
pine biotech
with almost zero knowledge of
bioinformatics
uh i literally didn't know what data
sets
meant what is ncbi nothing i mean you
understand what i mean by
saying zero so i joined initially it's
almost an year i'm associated with fine
biotech and i'm very happy for that
so uh i joined as a growth ambassador
initially
and as an ambassador i was given several
tasks and
at that time i went through the portal
of find biotech and learn
all the omics courses in which i had to
give exams of
you know all the small small self
assessment courses
later on i went and developed a student
community club under pine biotic that is
named as psionics
i am currently the president of cyanomix
and we have
two to three sessions every month that
is every thursday
on certain topics of bioinformatics
like we have how to do a literature
review that i am doing tomorrow
we also have expertise talks we also
have
interviews and press presentation of
projects by
phd students or undergraduates or
graduate students
so later on near december i started this
psionics club
and when i was ready knowing all the
knowledge not all
but basic knowledge of bioinformatics my
mentors said that i was ready to apply
that knowledge to a real project so i
was always interested in
neuroinformatics
so my area of interest was
neurodegenerative disorder so i
chose multiple sclerosis as my disease
of interest
i found a data set and later on went
ahead
and developed my own project so i worked
on this project for nearly three months
under the expert guidance of ilya dr
harpreet and dr mohit mazumdar
so later on after completing my project
i'm still in the process of submitting
my research
paper so my mentors have really helped
me to edit and you know justify my
mistake
organize the structure of my research
paper but before the research paper
comes out i went ahead and made my own
poster and i decided to present it to
the upcoming conferences
so last week i presented my this poster
on the
medicinal conference 2021 and i won the
second prize for the best poster
research poster category
so it has really helped me a lot
so from growing from level 0 to a
greater level applying big data analysis
and my mentors over here have really
really supported me
not just for the project but they also
supported me in networking i have
significantly grown
in terms of communication networking
talking with experts and everything
and so yeah i won the second prize and
i'm looking forward to my next
conference presentation
and i also submitted my this project to
international society for computational
biology of which i am presenting this
friday that is 23rd
so i'm looking forward and i would
really recommend
to anyone who want to learn about dry
lab and data analysis
to enter this fellowship and really give
it a try because
once you enter you will get to know that
how much it was worth it
and i'm always thankful for my mentors
so thank you so much
what about the psionics club routine
tomorrow's meeting
yeah correct so tomorrow for uh is
thursday as i said we have ceramic
sessions every thursday so tomorrow we
have a group of students
on some members in ceramics club who are
interested
in knowing about how to conduct a
literature review and how to go on
further to write a review paper or a
research paper
so tomorrow in the cyomics club the
theme of the session is how to do a
literature review
so i would be giving you a detailed uh
description of
how to do a literature review because i
have been through those stages and there
would be
other mentors also to guide you so as a
student i can
show it better to you that what
difficulties you would face as a starter
as a first-time person who is leaving a
literature review
so i warmly invite you all to tomorrow's
session of cyanomix club at 6
pm ist also if you want to join the club
all the links would be available
in the description box so just we have
already shared it thank you hsp
we daily update everything like the
sessions going on the upcoming
events and everything in the ceramics
look so
i hope to see you all there as well
thank you
thank you so much ruthvi now i would
like to invite
navia for sharing her experience with us
over to young
okay navia i'll just check
hi everyone so i'm a research fellow at
pine biotech
i basically joined pine biotech about a
month ago
and i'm new to the field of
bioinformatics and i didn't really know
much about the subject
and since we're having online classes
from college i couldn't get any
practical knowledge or hands-on
experience
for that matter so in order to have
wider perspective and practical
knowledge about the subject i
joined find biotech and my journey so
far has been flourishing
i am now familiar with so many new
techniques and technology
and of course they're working that i
didn't even know existed a month back
i've had
tremendous growth in this short span of
time and i'm really looking forward to
learn more and obviously it has all been
possible because of the extraordinary
guidance of mentors dr mohit dr harpiqua
and our very own ceo idiots so thank you
this wouldn't have been possible without
your help